we talked today about pandemic influenza
viruses in the past and in the future
and what it means to really make and try
to get a universal influenza virus
vaccine when we talk about influenza and
particularly pandemic influenza meaning
paid epidemic which has global
dimensions then we always have to think
of 1918 and what this slide shows us is
the life expectancy in the United States
from about 1900 to 2001
both female and male and we see that in
1900 the average life expectancy was
barely over 45 years forty-seven years
and then we see fortunately an increase
in life expectancy all the way up to
2001 and if we are thinking about the
baby girl who won in 2016 we are talking
about a life expectancy of way over 80
years the curve which we see here
however has one very remarkable deep of
about 11 years and that was the result
of the pandemic of 1918 1919 of
influenza so this is a an event which
has historic dimensions the life
expectancy was reduced by about 11 years
and was a resort authors influenza
outbreak from about November of 1918 to
February of 1919 in the United States we
had about 3/4 of a million deaths and
worldwide we are thinking that maybe up
to about hundred
million people died during this pandemic
of 1918 1919 it's always sources
sometimes we theatres influenza pandemic
is the Spanish flu and this had to do
that Spain so this was doing regular and
Spain was at the time neutral and the
only newspapers were the press could
only report from these neutral countries
in Spain was the only country at the
time which reported about the influenza
outbreak and that's why it was called
the Spanish flu but that didn't mean
there was no flu in France or there was
no flu in in the UK testing country
because these were countries which were
involved in World War one and there was
a lot of influence in fact in terms of
the u.s. involvement more people died in
the military of influenza as compared to
direct military action so this is really
something which is quite dramatic and
when we talk about global epidemics
pandemics of influenza we sometimes
really think about a virus which was
raised at Weston 1918-1919 pandemic the
next slide shows us in electron
micrograph and this was taken by a
student of mine dear young Chui and what
we can see here is a virus which has RNA
to segment the genome and we can see one
RNA in the center and then around
there's one RNA segments there are seven
other RNAs which are making up the
genome of the influenza virus and then
on the outside around this RNA is lipid
membrane which is provided by the host
cell and then there are very importantly
in this lipid membrane we have inserted
the surface spikes
which are referred to as the
hemagglutinin and we will receive their
different subtypes in terms of the h1
but very sort of intimated already we
had about 18 different hemagglutinin
subtypes and then we have also the the
amenities and as shown here one of the
subtypes of the numerators is the head
one so this is actually a virus it is
very very small if the if you have
computer in front of you then it's
really 20 inches 15 inches in diameter
and a cell which gets infected by it
such an influenza virus would be the
size of the World Trade Center the old
World Trade Center or the Empire State
Building in New York City and one of
these virus particles can infect the
Empire State Building and within about
eight hours about hundred thousand new
virus particles have being made and you
can see that such a virus replication
such a burst of virus replication can
actually result in the death of same
thing that's it
so the more one of the take-home
messages of what discussion today is
that there is a lot of variation there
is a lot of genetic variation of
antigenic variation and in terms of
influenza viruses and the important
antigenic variation is on the outside so
again we are talking about the
hemagglutinin and we are talking about
the new many days which are the surface
proteins on the buyers and that is what
our immune system is actually
recognizing and again a very good point
we are talking about extremely variation
genetic variation and that's actually is
the reason why we don't have any good
vaccine because there's a lot of this
going on and as you probably know there
are other viruses which are similar in
terms of this genetic antigenic
variation so this is a dental grams of
the lengths of these bars here of these
branches will reflect the diversity of
the different viruses and on the Left we
have here the influenza virus diversity
of the hemagglutinin and this is shown
here and very importantly over cells to
look at the ball which is telling us
what the degree of variability of
variation is and in this case it is 5%
so the length of this bar reflects it
difference in 5% that if we look now at
the other diversity in terms of viral
proteins we have here HIV and again you
can see here the diversity is quite
dramatic if you compare it to what we
just discussed before in terms of
influencer in a while each a HIV is
actually a little bit less but
continually that is also one of the
reasons why we don't healthier the
vaccine against HIV because the virus is
constantly changing and even within one
patient that can't be dramatic
differences in terms of a sort of the
cloud of different HIV viruses and then
we also with here the hepatitis E virus
the protein the diversity and again you
can see here if you just look at the bar
again this is five percent difference
and one can see here that the different
variants of hepatitis C virus in terms
of the e protein is also quite dramatic
so this is something we should be very
much aware of that if you see for
example we have wonderful vaccine
against measles virus measles and that
has to do that the virus doesn't change
and I will briefly discuss why that is
so as we go out now if you look at the
diversity of the influence of our
evening in more detail we are just
looking here we have now a different
ball here shows a 7%
diversity and in blue we have the worm
hemagglutinin and there are actually now
18 different ones and then if group two
hemagglutinin and there are six of those
in terms of human disease in terms of
human disease we have only seen so far
over the last hundred years we are
seeing h1 we have seen humans since 1918
h2 and we also have seen h3 so these are
the only subtypes h1 h2 and h3 which we
as humans have seen over the last
hundred years now the epidemiology of
influenza viruses is quite interesting
it's complex so the next slide shows
actually the different influenza viruses
which are circulating in the human
population and as I mentioned before we
have the 1918 and that was an h1n1 virus
and that we briefly discuss a little bit
more what we know about the h1n1 virus
and these viruses were present from 1918
until 1957 and then we got actually a
new pandemic strain which is referred to
as h2 n2 in 1957 and that was with us
for 11 years so this is a virus which
has a different image leutnant different
from the h1 and there's h2 virus with
the different your mate is n2 or
circulating for 11 years
and then in 1968 yet another pandemic
strain emerged and that actually it is
h3n2 virus is still with us now in 1977
another h1 virus read another h1n1 virus
appeared and this one actually is very
similar to our strains which we are
circulating in 1950 and this is really
surprising and that myers was with us
for about from 1977 to 2009 and this
virus was replaced by what we refer to
as a pandemic h1n1 in 2009 so at the
present time the earth h3n2 viruses near
Earth page one and one pandemic h1n1 and
we have influenza B viruses in France OB
viruses do not occur in terms of these
different subtypes which we have seen
with respect to influenza A viruses but
B viruses also changed and that is shown
in the changing color if you look at
different years slightly different
colors in terms of the influence of
beavers and what this should illustrate
is that we can get reinfected in about
if you get infected in 2016 for example
in two or three years the virus has
changed sufficiently that by 2019
probably can get reinfected within a
prison in France a virus because it has
continuously changed and that is
referred to as antigenic drift there is
in terms of the influenza A viruses when
a new hemagglutinin such as h2 or a new
hemagglutinin such a ch3 appears not
only upon a new pandemic strain and that
is ruthless and the genic shift now we
already talked about the 1918 situation
they we had quite a lot of races assured
in terms of the old the estimates are up
two hundred million people died in 1918
1919 in the u.s. these are the
illustrates the severity of the
influenza pandemic pandemic Sentosa
deaths in terms of the United States as
I said we had record a million in 1918
in 1957 this was a much milder one this
was the appearance of the h2 of the 10th
70,000 the h3 was even milder in 1968 in
the 2009 pandemic yet even milder than
that so this is quite important in terms
of the different influenza viruses
coming back to the 1918 one we I should
have mentioned before namely that the
bottom line shows that we don't have any
viable viruses from the period before
1933 and the 1918 virus is actually an
extinct virus however it was possible by
by in sequencing technology and this was
developed by jeffery taubenberger who
was at the time at the Armed Forces
Institute of Pathology in Washington and
he is now at the NIH so by using
material from soldiers who died in 1918
and this slide shows a long block so
you've sort of sort of translucent
material here is actually a paraffin
block and the dark material which we can
see here is material from the from the
soldier who died in 1918 and by using
this material and doing polymerase chain
PCR reaction sequencing it was possible
by Jeffery table to actually get the
secret
oh this 1918 virus and with the
technology which we developed here at
Mount Sinai it was an possible in the
liquor referred to this technology is
reverse genetics because we are making a
V so the RNA is the genome which we
talked about it there aid RNA segments
which I discussed before but then by
using DNA and transecting putting into
cells the eight RNA segments in right
here which express the different RNA
players different RNA segments and then
also in terms of the protein expression
plasmids improve transfection with these
12 plasmids actually then resulted in
the rescue of these viruses and this was
then paper which was actually quite well
received The Lancet the the input
British Medical Journal selected is
paper of the Year 2005 so more than ten
years ago we were able to reconstruct
the extinct 1918 Spanish influenza virus
and characterize it in terms of its
virulence and in terms of its different
properties so we actually know quite a
lot about this virus now because we have
it in the laboratory we have to work
with this virus under special conditions
which are referred to is biosafety level
3 conditions where we can make sure that
the virus does not escape and does not
cause any harm and which is done under
very careful conditions so this is the
story about the 1918 Spanish influenza
pandemic virus which we reconstructed in
the laboratory and very dumpy at the
time was he still at the cities
he was able under very stringent
biosafety conditions to get the first
complete letters with all the eight
genes from the 1918 virus now we have
talked about the different influenza
viruses which infect humans again we
have only h1 h2 and h3 but there are
other viruses particularly those which
come from Birds avian influenza viruses
and they have been shown to actually
occasionally to infect humans and so we
have for example if we look here age 5 &
6 in terms of the 2016 china this virus
age 5 and 6 was identified in china and
we have also for example in age 7 but
h5n1 which is shown here this was a
famous builder as we do a little bit
more about this but we are also a h7 if
for different age 7 actually we have 3 H
7 and 9 we have the H 7 and 3 we have
the page 7 and 2 and we have the H 7 and
7 so you one can see there are quite a
lot of these and even in foreign
services and they have been shown to
infect actually occasionally humans this
is something which many people are
worried about particularly if we talk
about the bird flu this is the h5n1
virus and this virus has actually caused
a lot of different problems in the in in
the Butley protein factories
particularly in China and we
actually very nervous that this would be
something which we could jump into
humans trying to move forward so we have
a slide here it shows us the
distribution of these a Haven influenza
viruses and we can see that in yellow
that these avian influenza viruses have
been found in white birds in poetry and
as we can see in terms of the red
squares there were also h5n1 out cases
in humans quite a lot of people actually
died as a result of these infections the
number of cases is probably much much
higher than is being shown here because
for the WH ol only recognizes cases
which are confirmed by laboratory
mistakes here and they have to be
shipped to either the US the Center for
Disease Control over to the to London
and one can should they understand that
there are many more cases or subclinical
infections in these different countries
whether it was Vietnam in China so it is
quite interesting that these h5n1 cases
have been recruited they are real it is
likely however that these are these
human cases are the result of large
doses which are inhaled by people
dealing with infected brewer's infected
chicken and so far there is no evidence
that the virus has been has been
transmitted from one rat from one person
to the other so these are very potential
new pandemic strains which might jump
into humans so what can we do against
these different influenza viruses and we
had actually two different classes of
fda-approved influenza virus drugs and
these are the so called ion channel
blockers amantadine or 9:13 and these
are only effective against the e-type
virus is not the B viruses but but there
are also many resistant influenza virus
strains resistance against amantadine so
that the only rule works which we are
many days inhibitors and there are two
types and a media and also time of year
and they are effective against both
influenced a Israel has influenza B
viruses so this is something which is
important and we should be aware of
these different works which we have
they're probably underutilized in
particularly in cases of severe
influenza MERS infections we should
really think about these anti virals
which are fairly safe verses and
represent a modality in output in terms
of trying to treat and also
prophylactically use them against
influenza MERS infections
the second major sort of to will be
health against influenza virus
infections are vaccines and that's sort
of what I'm going to highlight now
starting with the different types of
influenza virus vaccines which we have
we have inactivated influenza virus
vaccine so they are not inactive but
these are viruses which are grown up and
then inactivated by formaldehyde so that
the virus
not infectious anymore but the protein
is actually raining this being
administered by injection it can
actually induce an immune response which
are which is protective there is also if
the approved attenuated influenza virus
vaccine which is given through the nose
intranasally and that is a lie flares
but it is highly attenuated meaning very
very weak it barely replicates but it
actually can induce a very good immune
response in the nose and in the upper
respiratory tract which is important
because that's the area the location
where the influenza virus is replicating
and then though recently a fourth class
of influenza virus vaccines has been FDA
approved and that is a recombinant
protein the hemagglutinin and that
protein is being made in baculovirus by
baculovirus insect cells and it is
injected also and this is a quite
effective vaccine against the
hemagglutinin and therefore against the
virus and particularly in terms of
people who have allergies against egg
products because both of the inactivated
and attenuated strains are gone in in
grenada takes the recombinant one does
not has never seen in avian cell and
therefore people who are allergic to
alien proteins king there safely used is
a competent influenza virus vaccine now
there are as everyone knows the vaccines
in for influenza virus against influenza
virus are good however they are
underutilized and they are not perfect
they are not hundred percent and that is
one of the reasons why we are looking
for a better vaccine specifically you
have to understand
was mentioning before we have three
different influenza viruses circulating
at the present time we have h1n1 viruses
with h3n2 viruses and you have actually
two different kinds of influence of the
virus is circulated if you look at the
names for example if you look at B
police pain here that means it's a virus
virus isolated first in Brisbane and
isolated number 60 and in was isolated
in 2008 and as you can see for the
influenza vaccine formulation for
2016-2017 the vaccine which we are going
to get starting in the fall has actually
four different components unfortunately
were again in h1n1 and h3n2 and two
different influenza B virus components
now unfortunately the dismay ability in
the virus forces us to change the
vaccine formulation very often and this
slide here shows just look at the red
and the black this is from 2000 to 2010
we have an h1 and h3 and the B virus
component and the different years show
in red that devised for the vaccine had
to be changed from the previous year so
in many instances two out of three at
least one out of three for example in
2001 2002 have had to be changed there's
only one single year which was came
through
2003 2004 there was no change from the
previous vaccine formulation however
there is for example one year 2008 to
2009 they always say components have to
be changed so this is something which is
important and makes it very difficult to
manufacture in flying somewhere as
magazines because one has to take into
account the continuing change which we
discussed before it is also disturbing
that in the case of the 2009 the red
curve shows and then explain actually
hit the United States we had the
majority of the influenza cases were
already in October November and the new
line shows when the vaccine was actually
shipped and then it takes distribution
should from the manufacturers and then
it had to be distributed to
pediatricians to Walmart's pharmacies
etc so one and then it takes another
1015 days until the next scene really
works
so this is really something quite
dramatic in terms of that something as
important as a pandemic strain we are
not able to really manufacture the
vaccine strain for the 2009 pandemic in
[Music]
sufficient Affairs so that it would have
an impact a positive impact or an impact
in terms of avoiding influenza
fortunately there's pandemic horribles
of very very mild and we actually sort
of so to speak
lucky so now in terms of the
difficulties of the vaccines one is they
have to be changed constantly in a new
pandemic we are not ready because it
takes too long to manufacture it
and then also many times the vaccine
strain doesn't match the circulating
strain because the decision of what kind
of strain is actually added to the
vaccine is made about a year before one
actually vaccinate and therefore many
times the circulating strains are not
what we would like to are not matched
very well to the vaccine strength and
are the vaccine efficacy is actually
lower so therefore the question is how
can we do better and the answer to that
is a universal influenza vaccine one
which would be effective against
different strains and against different
types and subtypes of the influenza
virus so and let me specifically see
right away the data I'm going to show
are all in the laboratory so we do not
have universal influenza virus vaccine
at this point but it should show us what
we can what we are thinking could be a
solution and the way we are doing this
is make sure the collaboration between
three different laboratories at Mount
Sinai
this is Florian Kramer's laboratory at
solstice laboratory in my own and so the
idea is that we are trying to make a
vaccine against the conserved region is
important protein on the outside of the
virus and we found that don't show or
the data but that the there are two
domains so we have to think about the
membrane of the viruses actually down
here and the hemagglutinin is sort of in
seeded into this membrane about
thousands of these spikes through a
virus protocol
and the store which is in green is
actually very much conserved but it is
also not a very immuno dominant in terms
of the immune response encompassed the
head which is shown here in brownish
color is actually moving you know
dominant it is simply make more
antibodies against it and unfortunately
is also changing quite a lot so this is
what we are seeing in in humans and we
hope that a vaccine which consists of
the chameleon hemagglutinin which has
the same store as the one we have seen
already but a different in in terms of
h5 which we as humans have never seen is
a hope that such a vaccine which we
induce an immune response against the
store and not much against the age-wise
because we have never seen this so it's
like being naive towards this head and
by then giving a second vaccination with
yet another vaccine which in this case
has a different exotic head like an age
six we would hope that there is some
amplification of the b-cells against the
immuno sub-dominant stalk of the
hemagglutinin and we would hope that a
lot of these antibodies against the
against the stock would then protect us
in terms of different strains belonging
to a one-handed opening if you remember
this one of our earlier slides we would
like to make also a vaccine against the
group to hemagglutinin Israelis
influenza B virus tor component and so
having there were three components who
one store people
- stork and an influenza B store we
should be able to actually make a better
vaccine so this year again shows us that
we have a situation here now we are we
are going with into animals the animals
are in this case we are talking about
Mice and mice have never seen influenza
they are not a reservoir for the
infection and of influenza and we can
see we have to prime the mice with the
DNA and all between Israel using he
again irrelevant health of the
hemagglutinin but what is important is
we have the we are planning with a
particular stalk and then we are
boosting with two different vaccines
again a different head with chimera gage
six in the Cameo gauge five and then we
challenge with a virus which is higher
the different from 1934 1947 2009 or
even a completely different like in age
five or even age 6 H 6 hemagglutinin so
again by vaccinating in essence with a
vaccine that amplifies the conserved
regions of the hemagglutinin we hope
that we will make the inducing humans a
vaccine which is quite protective and
this is shown here where we have again
some antibodies against the stove if we
come with the first magazine we get our
different head response but war in terms
of the stroke and yet more in terms of
the story after the second
vaccinations with camera at age five so
this is important which can show now
that in terms of the vaccination with
canary constructs is that should be
leading to a protection we are using
here in 1934 stock in in the mouse and
became protect against the virus which
is that's almost 70 years later we get
complete protection real challenges
challenges master don't lose any rate
the black curve shows were happening we
have no vaccination and the control is
in light pink so this is sort of showing
us that over a long period of time in
mice we get complete protection we can
also show that we can protect in this
case against h5 challenge or actually in
h6 challenge we can also protect these
mice with vaccine protocol the approach
strategy which I just discussed so this
is quite important we very they are also
able to show that these mice are the
base are protected against different
subtypes we can also show that we can do
similar experiments with a group to
stalk and we are able to show that the
mechanism by which this happens is
through antibodies by a passive transfer
now there specifically we showed that
these pilate protective stalk antibodies
mediate the antiviral activity by the
mechanism by which the antibody is
actually let me show you this here this
is a model for optimal in their
induction of antibody dependent
said that cell the linux cytotoxic
mediated
cell-mediated cytotoxicity ADCC antibody
dependent
cell-mediated cytotoxicity and these are
effective cells these antibodies here
it's go against the stalk and we found
it should be very recently that by
having the interaction between the FC
portion of the hemagglutinin and the FC
receptor on effector cells and a second
contact point which is say like acid of
the effector cell and help of the
agglutinin we get actually induced
antibody ADC antibody mediated cell
mediated cytotoxicity and this is a very
interesting mechanism we have at this
point the NIH has made preparations of
these new vaccines so this is an H five
candidates 5/1 and the Evora prep these
are about 10,000 doses each in terms of
the chimera age eight here and we hope
that these kinds of vaccine vaccines
will be introduced into the into humans
and that we can measure the immune
response against such vaccines and
hopefully they are his protective has to
be able to show in animals we have only
shown this in mice we have shown it in
guinea pigs in reality in ferrets but
obviously what is important is whether
that kind of vaccine approach will also
work in humans
so in summary let me then sort of repeat
or highlight what I have said we are
trying to make a universal influenza
vaccine by reducing the immuno dominance
of the immigrant
and thereby increasing the
immunogenicity of the immigrants talk
and we have to remember that the
hemagglutinin head is really what
changes dramatically but the store is
much more conservative and that if we
can sort of vaccinate against this
conserved domain we should be able to
make a immune response which would
protect us against many different
challenge strains and obviously these
are difficult vaccines they also have to
be long-lasting and also haven't really
discussed this we also hope that by
there's redirecting growth in human
response from the head towards a store
we should also make better immune
responses against in your many days
which is the second plateau coating on
the surface of the virus and by having
antibodies against in your many days
which is always a much more conservative
much more conservative than the head of
the hemoglobin we hope to make a very
efficient vaccine which should protect
us against all kinds of antigenic
variants including new pandemic strains
which will there is no doubt that such
viruses will procure in the future so
this is again this vision we have for a
human universal influenza vaccine again
we have not been in humans this is a
very long process but we hope that by
redirecting again the immune response
away from the earth by using irrelevant
aids which we have never seen we want to
amplify the immune response against the
stalk of the Chimera gage v 1 and Omega
H 6:1 and thereby protect against the
different variants Israel is different
subtypes and we believe that we will
need a group once taught a group to
store and there was an influence of evil
I was talking again this is work which
we are doing in collaboration through a
famous laboratory
Dorothy Austin's laboratory and my own
thank you very much and I'm happy to
answer any questions